foreign
she was first diagnosed with anorexia
when we were 14. for several years she
was in and out of hospitals and
treatment centers and she's back now
basically where we were when we were 14
and extremely severe but the reality is
is I am angry
[Music]
John with the Dr John delone show the
greatest
parenting and marriage and mental health
podcast ever created
so glad that you joined us on this
beautiful day it's beautiful morning out
here I'm in Nashville and wherever you
happen to be listen to this podcast I'm
glad that you are joining us or watching
us on on the Internet it's on the
YouTubes
um if you want to be on the show give me
a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 and leave a message and
we'll give you a call back all right so
drum roll
uh maybe they'll edit a drum roll in
there probably not so
for the last few months I've been
getting direct messages and emails and
even a couple people have sent cards and
letters saying asking
what happened to James
used to be John and James and Kelly back
in the in the basement back in the on
the first floor down in in the hole and
then we moved up to the big kids
um studio and then James and Kelly and I
came up here
and we made YouTube magic that sounds so
it sounds gross Oogie but
slowly James faded away like the old
Neil Young song he was here a few less
days and then a few less days
and then I would look up and say James
James and he was just gone
and so people have been asking what
happened to James did James get fired
we cannot we can all hope but no he
actually quit he quit my show actually
he's he's here's the truth he is
um like the executive producer of this
one no I don't know what you do what is
your job now
he's the producer producer a senior
producer what's the
senior executive listen he's really
fancy and he on the side got this show
off and running off the ground
and turned it I mean launched it into
what it is and so there's a hundred
percent chance that none of this show
exists none of it without James and he
was uh instrumental and being my friend
and we'd go out and have drinks and try
to figure out like hey you can't say
that on the air because you sound
clinically insane and I don't know what
you're talking about and I would get mad
and throw a temper tantrum because I was
acting like a nine-year-old and I didn't
know what how do you anyway I didn't
know any of this stuff and so James has
fully transitioned out of this show and
he is the senior producer of a bigger
fancier show I was giving him a hard
time because there's always those
stories right when you're watching like
Behind the Music when they're like I was
in this really big band but I believed
in the little band and I joined the
little band now the little band has
taken over the world that's James
opposite story he was like man I'm
working on a really famous thing and I'm
helping this idiot out I'm gonna stick
with the big famous thing so well done
James well done but in exciting so on
behalf of America James thank you and on
all honestly on behalf of my family you
helped change my whole family's life so
thank you so much
um behind closed doors I did do
something I never thought I would ever
do
and for those of you who are waiting for
the pause you know there's just a very
few things that I wouldn't actually do
because there's not a lot I wouldn't
just give a shot just to see what would
happen
but I I bought James the finished
Stratocaster that's the first and only
time I've ever purchased a fender
product
no actually I bought an amp now it's
happening now now it's like a slippery
slope but anyway
James thanks brother appreciate you and
and further exciting news
Kelly is now the are you a senior
producer you're you're running the show
Kelly is driving kids
so what's your is it are you senior
producer I'm producer producer all right
we're gonna work really hard and get you
to senior it's not the goal I don't know
what the goal is I don't need the world
and Jenna is can I say she's the new the
new associate producer associate
producer Ben is running the the air the
board which is dope
we got all man we got we it's we got
Andrew over there on the computers on on
the screens
but sometimes it's Nate Dogg I don't
ever know what's going on over there but
listen to this good news though since
Kelly has taken over as producer of the
show
it's like gotten Millions literally more
listeners and followers and so I think
when it all comes down to it
Kelly's doing a better job than James
but James got it off the ground I gotta
talk bad about you because you left me
you broke up with me and now I have to
inflate my own ego but
um so that's where James has been that's
where James is going and he just stick
his head in every once in a while just
to make sure we haven't completely
gotten off the rails so brother thank
you so much I'm grateful for you
Kelly I trusting you with everything I'm
trusting you with everything
we'll see if that's uh it's good or not
it's been my lifelong dream to be a
YouTuber and so don't don't wreck this
train for me
no offense but I don't know if the train
wrecks if it'll be all my fault
we even left the station all right let's
go to Margaret and Arlington what's up
Margaret
Hi how are you I'm sorry to hear about
James I know what a quitter right but
it's okay that's okay we're doing good
with Adam we've got a great game that's
right we got yes we got two brilliant
women running the show now so that's
awesome
what's up
um yeah so I will first thank you for
taking my call
um I was hoping
um that you could give me some advice on
how to
um
basically let go of the anger and
resentment that I feel towards my sister
so that I can better help her and
support her through her eating disorder
and Recovery oh man that's tough how old
is she how old are y'all
lead with that Margaret lead with that
um so 33 twins this is extra personal uh
yeah so we're pretty close tell me about
your sister
um well it's over 33 we she was first
diagnosed with anorexia when we were 14.
have you ever have you ever wrestled
with distorted eating no no not me
personally have you ever wrestled with
any sort of anxiety
yeah
um
yeah I had bad like postpartum anxiety
and depression a couple years ago when I
had my daughter okay what about when you
were young
what about when you were young when I
was young no no
there's depression in my family and my
dad is bipolar okay
um so there is some family history with
mental illness there but 14 15 16 like
your childhood
um your teenage years you walked
alongside your sister while she was
really struggling but you didn't have
similar struggles just somewhere else
correct okay wow okay all right let's go
ahead so okay so she
um she's 14. we were 14 when she was
first diagnosed it was very severe
um for several years she was in and out
of hospitals and treatment centers
um and then I would say in our 20s
um she she got to a good place where she
was coping with it and managing it
um living a full productive life we were
all kind of like reads easy for a while
um and then
a couple years ago right around the time
that covet hit she quit her job to stay
at home with her daughter to be a
stay-at-home mom
um and then
she started gobbling again in like diets
and workout programs and at first it was
just oh I want to lose the baby weight
um but it was only a couple like a
matter of a couple of months maybe
before she was full and spiraling again
yeah
um and she's back now basically where we
were when uh where she was when we were
14 and
extremely severe
case she's been in two treatment
programs in the last two years
um like inpatient treatment programs the
first one she checked herself out early
AMA because she just didn't want to be
there anymore right and then the second
time she was actually kicked out early
because she wasn't following the roles
of the program
um and I guess
you know on top of the stress and the
worry and the concern that I have for
her
um
I just struggle a lot with anger towards
these choices that she's making and
um and I feel like
this time is different
um I like I know that she can get better
and move on
um because I've seen her do it before
but this time feels different it feels
like she's giving up and she's told me
that when she feels like her family is
upset with her or angry with her
um that she just
um shuts down and doesn't want to fight
it anymore so but the reality is is I am
angry
and I'm
hard not to watch her
um you know I hear you say a lot that
behavior is a language or like yeah
behavior is a language and her behavior
says that she just doesn't want to be
here anymore that she doesn't want to
live and that she's slowly killing
herself and making us all watch it and
it's maddening yeah yeah uh
your anger is is Justified it's okay
um don't beat yourself up and feel
guilty about it yeah don't don't feel
horrible for being mad because I know
it's like I get it it's a serious mental
illness and
it's not like she can just stop right
um change yeah and normally you've heard
me say I'm I'm much more context
specific when it comes to like my ADHD
won't let me like nope you got that's no
excuse you got to figure it out right
um but when it comes to this you know
this but I I hear Mo generally that it's
the most or if the top one or two
um most lethal mental health
issues in the world and most people
don't know that anorexia kills more
people than depression right
um it's a scary thing and it's
especially scary watching somebody you
love who also is the mother of your
niece or does she have one kid two kids
Jesus
um slowly suffocate themselves
I'm so sorry so don't feel guilty about
being upset that's okay that's you'd be
a weirdo if you weren't mad okay
um there's a difference between anger
and rage right
and there's a look here's the way I
would explain it if my son I may have
explained this on the show before my if
my son gets up in the middle of the
night
and he's
um sick
and he comes into my room and says Daddy
I don't feel good and I'm like well like
what do you mean how can I help and then
he barfs all over my bed
I can be mad that I'm covered in barf
I can't be mad at my little boy for
coming to the one place he knows he
feels safe when he doesn't feel good
right I can be frustrated I could tell
him don't ever barf on my bed again dude
do that somewhere else but yeah um so
you're like being mad at this situation
that the your sister who let's be honest
are y'all are y'all identical twins
no we're not identical okay fraternal
twins then yeah yeah okay you're
watching a part of yourself out there
walking around right yeah that's gotta
be tough
make peace with the tough okay
um
here's the back end like what do you do
now what do you want to do now what is
your family talking about doing what are
y'all thinking about doing
oh we don't really know she um
she is resisting going back into an
inpatient program she doesn't want to do
it again
um so she's kind of fighting that
um but everybody her entire team her
doctors or therapists everyone is
telling her if you don't
get this help if you don't change these
behaviors you
will die right and
um she has she ever been involuntarily
committed
she no no
um not yet anyway okay but we're looking
at that possibility okay that's a huge
deal so people listening like why can't
you just make her go it's a huge deal to
take away somebody's civil rights that
somebody else comes in and says you're
crazy that's been abused throughout
history and so
um that's a usually a last Last Resort
when somebody's barely hanging on
another option is somebody's got to step
in and keep those kids safe
um how are those kids
God their dad is amazing um and he's
doing everything he can Okay
um you know the the thing that makes it
also difficult is they live on the other
side of the country for me so it's not
like I can just pop over yeah click in
on them or take them or whatever my
um you know my parents have gone out
there and helped out and taken them at
certain times just to help um and we do
what we can but I also am extremely
worried about how this is going to
affect them
so it'll affect them profoundly one yeah
yeah yeah no it'll be a huge deal
um and yeah that's going to be a
long-term Ripple through through the
family yeah
um
I can't I can think of few harder
situations than what you're in right now
and I wish I could tell you here just do
these three things and I can't
um you've got somebody that you love and
you care about and it's very close
closer to you than than probably your
husband probably her husband is closer
like y'all are right you'll share the
womb dude you're right y'all are in it
um
watching her be so sick
that she is she's tired and she's slowly
checking out
and it's I can think a few things harder
than that what I would tell you is
in addition to the anorexia my guess is
you've reached your limit on the lying
and the secrets and just talking to you
like you're stupid you know what I mean
if you if you spent time on people with
the story eating
they tell you things that are so
blatantly not true that it feels like
they're insulting you that you're stupid
right and it just gets exhausting to be
around like no no yesterday I'm not I
had like a five piece of pizza
a hundred percent you didn't right and
they're and just the stories get more
outlandish and sometimes it's less
watching the person be sick and it's
more just quit lying or weird Secrets or
making right just all of it turns into
this it's hard to be around yeah so
know this
she can be very very sick and
still make moves I hate to call it
manipulation because I know it's a part
of it's a function of the illness
but the lobbying grenades like when
you're mad at me it makes me just want
to die that's not fair don't own that
okay that's nonsense
um that's just that's just that's
manipulative and it's not I wouldn't
play that game the moment you say cool
I'm all in you look things are great I'm
just that's you being disingenuous right
that's not that's not cool
um I would be open and honest about how
you feel
and don't let her perfectionism and
blame and shame be cast on you and at
the same time this is going to be
probably the hardest thing you ever have
to do I would reach out to her and if
you can visit in person mm-hmm
and let her know I'm not going to try to
fix you
I can't sit here and watch you die
but I love you
I actually do have a trip planned out to
go see her okay
um and so that's also probably why I was
calling because I don't know what to say
when I do see her
I know my family wants me to I guess
kind of convince her to go back into
treatment yeah
um
so I know if I go to if I do that or try
I know she's just gonna shut down
absolutely and and I've I've got people
close to me that have struggled with
disorder eating and you're exactly right
most people I I'm very direct with
people I love who are hurting I'm
directing everybody who's hurting and
about what they need to be to do to get
on the path of healing and this one is
hard because the moment you launch into
it they shut down they shut off right
and that's where I would tell you
sitting down with her she doesn't need
to know that she's sick she knows
what she really needs is you to hold her
hand and say I love you it's really hard
for me to watch you die
but I love you and I'll do what I can to
take care of your kids
um but I love you
and that's the only way I found
personally I don't have any literature
on this this is just me sitting with
people the only way to get a crack in
the door to get some light in there
is that person's not trying to fix me
they're not trying to broke because I've
gotta because people with disorder even
have a game plan for that they don't
have a game plan for unconditional love
and skin to skin contact
right and you have to make space
um an analogy just came to my head and
what I'm going to tell you is going to
be very hard to hear is that okay
yeah sure okay
yeah what I'm going to tell you is real
hard to hear okay
my dad um it was a hostage negotiator
for the SWAT team in Houston and what
that meant was when somebody was going
to jump off of a building and they would
they had gone out on the ledge and they
were hanging on barely they would call
my dad they called the team in but my
dad would be one of the guys that would
go up and sit with that person and talk
to him until they came down all right
and he told me that
he would often go up there and within
just a minute or two he knew if that
person was going to jump or not
and almost always they didn't want to
jump but he said his concern would
almost invariably move towards he
thought they were going to fall
they're going to get tired and slip
they're gonna get exhausted and relax
their grip a little bit and they're
going to fall off right yeah and he said
whenever you walk into those situations
when people are at this stage of of
illness at this stage of hurt of this
stage of pain
he said you had to make sure you had
already asked yourself
am I going to watch when they jump
or am I going to listen when they hit
or am I going to cover my ears and duck
down
and here's what I'm telling you that
that lesson has been very important for
me throughout my life working with in
these moments because
you have to come up with your line
right
um am I going to watch this thing happen
in a slow motion train wreck or am I
going to call every psychiatric facility
and try to do an involved call the
police I'm gonna try to involunteer I'm
going to burn every bridge I have to
keep my sister alive
and also
I'm not gonna or am I going to draw a
boundary and say
I'll call you every day I'll write you
every day but I cannot watch the end of
this thing happen like that that's a
boundary you have to draw for yourself
okay I'm somebody who will exhaust the
go to the ends of the Earth but I'm also
a realist too
and that's a hard moment for you but I
want you and the people in your
community to be prepared for if she does
take her life if she does choose I am
not getting help that hey you can sleep
knowing I did what was right for us and
B
that's not your fault
and having some space there before you
enter into these conversations is really
important
and it sounds this is a call that I
don't normally have right it sounds like
I'm kind of a defeatist
um I just have been with too many people
in your sister's situation and it's it
can be very bleak
it can be very Bleak I can also say this
never lost one not that I've never had
somebody pass away I've had people turn
the corner but only through relationship
and treatment intense treatment
um have you told her you told like I
don't want you to die have you said
those words
how did she hear that
[Music]
um she just gets really quiet and she'll
say I don't want to die either or at
least that's what she used to say
um
and
you know she says she said in the past I
want to be here for my kids I don't want
to leave them
um
but like I said I I just it's different
now she's definitely it definitely feels
like she's given up and she's saying
things like well my eating disorder just
wants me dead so
I feel like that's what's gonna happen
so I think that if she says that that's
fair yeah I think you're right I think
it does want you dead
she needs to want to be alive
and you've heard the old story about
sobriety like you can't get clean for
your kids you can't get clean for your
spouse you gotta get clean for you you
have to decide I wanna I wanna I want a
different life
and most people decide they want a
different life they get to a place where
they can they don't want to hurt anymore
or they get to a place where
somebody's holding their hand and they
realize they're not alone
and usually it's a combination of the
two
okay but I think sitting if if she's if
she's if I'm in your situation I would
sit down and say I'm not here to fix you
I'm here to tell you I love you
okay you're smart you know all the
treatment plans you know all the stuff I
love you
cannot sit here and just watch you die
and um you can let her know I'm gonna
call everybody I know I'm gonna do
everything I can legally and otherwise
to force you into treatment because I
don't want to watch you die
but I also want you to know I'm not
going to try to fix you I can't do that
right so it's a both hand
um and have that hard conversation with
yourself with your family with her
husband whoever you need to have it and
create some go all in and have some
space right
or maybe the better way to say it is uh
run into the building that's on fire but
be connected to the oxygen hose outside
right yeah
yeah and that means you got to keep
yourself well during this whole thing
right you got to make sure you've got
someone you're talking to or a couple of
people you're talking to that you're
eating that you're exercising you're
walking around that you're sleeping when
you can that you're taking care of
yourself so that you can repel into this
mess
um for those of you watching this
um
I as much as anybody
I'm all about discipline I'm all about
just do it I don't care what you feel
just go go I don't feel like working out
work out anyway that's me that's who I
am
sort of eating is something else it's a
nightmare and
um there's some compelling evidence out
there that it's it's one of the few that
is truly genetic right and it's got a
history throughout time it's not just
because social media is it that
exacerbates it but
it's been with us for a long time it is
and it is a nightmare and so just saying
you just gotta it doesn't work with
anorexia
um relationship and true desire to
change
true Relentless desire to be alive and
to be whole that's what helps people in
those moments and that can only happen
with a team of professionals
so if you are struggling with anorexia
you're you're you're worth a better life
you're worth a better life
you're worth laughing and you're worth
peace and if you love somebody who's
struggling with anorexia call everybody
call everybody get the resources you
need and when you call everybody also
let that person know I can't fix you
only you can but I love you and I'll be
here with you
be here with you we'll be right back
hey folks Dr John deloney here look we
live in a culture that glorifies the
grind everything's about corrosion and
killing it and go go go go go and we
like And subscribe and follow anyone
with tips on how to hack our way to
doing more and being more and we
sacrifice sleep at the altar of
productivity and my friends we are
exhausted hustling is well and good but
burnout is real and when you're running
hard you must remember to recharge your
body with sleep sleep is the Cornerstone
to physical and mental health and for me
getting great sleep starts with a great
mattress that's why I love dream Cloud
right now dream cloud is running an
awesome offer for our listeners 599
dollars in accessories plus an
additional 250 dollar discount that's a
total of eight hundred and forty nine
dollars in accessories and savings
you'll get pillows a mattress protector
and luxury sheets it's time to ditch
burnout culture and start prioritizing
your sleep go to dreamcloudsleep.com
deloni or or dreamcloudsleep.com and
enter promo code deloni to get your new
mattress today and enjoy 849 dollars in
savings and accessories
all right we're back let's go to Candace
in Boise what's up Candace
hi hi Dr deloney what are you doing
I'm so grateful uh it's a pleasure to
speak with you what's up
new to me but it's a little bit new I am
a grandmother of six kids okay and I
have a situation where
one of my sons went uh through a pretty
hard divorce last year it was a shocker
to him when his wife asked him for her
divorce and come to find out she was had
other interests
in another man and unfortunately has
went down just a horrible path and it's
been really hard on my son watching this
go on from the sidelines now
but in this process he thought that he
would try online dating and
did go out on some dates and
well I will call it fortunately but
him one of his acquaintances yes
acquaintances got pregnant one of his
acquaintances
that's the best grandma way to say that
one of his acquaintances one of his old
schoolmates
um okay so are you're going to be a new
grandma
gonna be a new Grandma okay and he's he
has wanted to be a dad for a long time
so
that is
my first very first thought when he told
me was oh my gosh you get to be a daddy
finally and I I was genuine I am
genuinely happy for him I was then and I
am now okay
the odd situation is that
since there wasn't a relationship before
the pregnancy
um neither one of them are pursuing a
stay relationship a couple relationships
afterwards and they've agreed to you
know be co-parents and she actually is a
parent uh she has two other children and
we've spent enough time with them that
uh she's an amazing Mama she's a very
generous mother when it comes to her
children's time spent with their dads
and I feel nothing
nothing bad about her at all because of
that I mean she's just she's amazing
so I guess my question comes in
what kind of boundaries
okay first of all I'm having a hard time
expressing to my son
what what my thoughts are about
his role to take with her I mean I I'm
encouraging I've spent time with them
with her kids
um
I just don't feel like he's connecting
who's he not connecting with with her or
with this baby well he's not connecting
with the baby he's not connecting
he's excited to be a dad I've we've been
to ultrasounds and that kind of thing
but he's not
he's not interested in what's going on
in the pregnancy really
and now I
is shocking to me because he's such he's
such a loving
loving man yeah I can I can tell you I
struggled with that and I was married
I didn't know what I it was I didn't
know what to do I didn't know how or I
didn't know anything about what has
happened with pregnancy
and I didn't I had to go read up like I
didn't I just didn't know and so
ultimately I had to have some hard
conversations about hey I I've I'm on
the outside here right and I we live
together and so I got to see the ins and
outs I didn't know what was happening so
I'm just trying I'm trying to just put
my my self in his shoes for a minute
to even yeah I know somebody's pregnant
I don't fully understand what all that
means you know what I mean and I'm just
going home to my apartment every night
and I'm not living with this situation
and so I can I can imagine there's a
disconnect there or a distancing
um do they go have coffee every once in
a while or whatever are they just going
about their lives when the baby's born
they'll figure it out
they're both kind of going on about
their lives and he has expressed to me
what what you just expressed okay that
he doesn't get it I mean the most recent
pregnancy in our family that he was
around was his sister like 10 years ago
so
yeah and she probably is her third one
of these and so there's some routine for
her
um this is just what happens when you
get pregnant and so I can imagine like
whenever if you remember back the first
time you get pregnant it's all new for
everybody and everybody's talking about
it and thinking about it and reading
about it and getting opinions from
friends now this is this is her third
right and she's figuring out how am I
gonna be a single mom of three kids now
and manage these two men in my life now
and whatever
um and she's probably dating too like
right so it's a whole bunch going on for
her so I can imagine there's just a
distancing there it sounds like the
bigger picture here and if he was on the
phone I'd be having a whole different
conversation
the bigger picture is
you had a picture of what it would be
like when he had his first baby and this
is not it
and you are trying to navigate this wild
world where two adults decided to hook
up one night they had a baby and they're
like great we'll be great parents see
you later and you know enough to know
it's not going to work like that over
time
but also they're both good people like
it let me put it this way we have a
picture in our head of when couples do
that that clearly they're idiots or they
are have mental health issues or they're
evil and you're dealing with two adults
who are kind and rational and lovely
people independently and they are
willing to work together in the middle
of a situation they didn't plan but is
here it doesn't fit the narrative right
and so we start spinning our wheels and
then when we start spinning our Wheels
we start trying to make other people do
things so that we can feel less spinny
does that make sense yeah
oh exactly exactly and I I can relate to
that although you know our other
children have been married and divorced
before and we I'm
I'm really close to those parents and I
think this one might just be a little
bit different just because I wanted it
for him for so long I think you're right
I think you want it for him for good
reason he sounds like he's a good guy he
sounds like he's going to be a good dad
you want him for so long but you wanted
it in a context where everybody's going
to be safe and this one's going to be
this is going to be a lot of tightrope
walking without a net right
because there's not a safety of of a
relationship that when things get messy
which they will we can fall back on that
together we're just gonna have to fall
back on our good adult decision-making
skills which I don't know about you but
mine aren't always very great right
which is why the relationship is so
important like my my wife is such an
important role part of this process
um
I would focus on if I'm you I well
actually what yeah what can I help you
with like how can I help
here I'm starting answering questions
well
I think I think you're right on track
and boundaries have been an issue for me
before and especially with this son
I'm really
struggling to not jump in there and say
you know how can I help you for example
get the bedroom set up how can I help
you get ready for this baby
attempting that and no listen I just
thinking back
thinking this Baby's gonna weigh like
nine pounds they're gonna be 24 inches
long we don't need a room for it and
like to say I mean I might as well be
like hey you just want to move to Mars
it was like my wife was like oh gosh I'm
married to a serial killer I was like
dude we could just like put it right
here and like next yeah what are we what
are we doing right but here's the thing
I didn't know
and if if
let's say my son
is
um married not married he finds out he's
expect he's gonna be a dad I would and
this is just the way I handle problems
is I would
um I don't see problems I handle
challenges I would say cool from here
until the first year through the first
that baby's first year you have to have
breakfast with me once a week
I'll figure that out and so I would
challenge you to do that same thing with
him
okay I am wanna we're gonna have
breakfast I wanna hear what you're
thinking how this is all going I wanna I
want to if you ever have questions for
me great and if we just sit there and
I'm gonna send you some questions for
humans cards we can just I just want to
get to know you better I I don't know
you very well I I've I think I know you
but I want you to ask me questions about
my life but no kid's gonna be like hey
Ma so when you're when the baby was
crowning right you're not no no son is
gonna ask his mom that but
in some of those questions for humans
there there's like what was the scariest
moment and you might be able to say when
that baby was leaving my body right and
he'll go oh gross you know I know it's
gross but right so they'll give you an
invitation into a conversation that
would be awkward otherwise to get into
um yeah but I think that's where you can
say okay let's let's paint me a picture
of what your home's gonna look like
paint me a picture of what you think
this will look like because those
diapers I had no idea
no idea
that a kid went through eight to ten
diapers a day
thought
one kid every second every second I had
no idea and so when they were like where
the diapers gonna go I'm thinking I
don't know like put them put one by the
kleenex box I didn't have any idea right
I didn't realize you had to have like a
back trucks up in the living room to
store all the diapers and that's just
for like a week and so I think just
saying hey but here's the focus not on
all of his deficiencies and where he's
not thinking you got to be thinking
about this not that
I love you and this is a scary time even
though it's exciting for you it's scary
time you got you're gonna have at least
one person always in your corner and
that's your Ma I'll be here in your
corner and
you have to have some weird
conversations normally you have them
with your wife you don't have that
luxury so you get to have them with your
mom all right and just kind of jump into
that a little bit and be really open
with him about saying if you don't want
to talk to me that's okay
and give him permission to walk away and
if he does that's his choice his as an
adult and it's gonna be really sad for
you and you're gonna have to deal with
your grief but you can't prop your you
can't make your son deal with your grief
right is that fair
yes
it's very fair and
I mean I think you hit all the nails on
the head I mean with boundaries being an
issue at various times in my life
I think that
being able to just focus on what is most
important to him will help me not focus
on
what what
exactly my perception was as to what his
life was going to look like have you
asked him hey what do you need right now
oh yeah
yeah especially since the divorce
because there's been it's been really
it's been really rough on him and
sometimes he just and he has said I just
need you to sit with me oh that's so
good yeah make that's so
so good and when moms sit with their
sons it's just I still like it when my
mom will just sit with me
and I'm an old man I I still love it and
she can also quietly ask me
hey are you gonna keep driving that car
because I think you're gonna die in it
right that's different than
you don't love your kids you're not
keeping them safe because you're driving
this little junkie truck that that's a
totally different conversation so I
think in the moments when you're just
being with them and you just sitting
with them and you can say
where's the bassinet gonna go
or
just for me because I'm a boundary free
mom
could I make a list of all the things
that I think I remember that you're
going to need and we can start
collecting them now
whether that's a
a like a storage unit for all the
diapers you're gonna need or a bassinet
or a car seat
um I'll go to a parenting class with you
or I'll teach you how to how to change a
diaper on a doll right I had somebody
help me do that it was that would not
work at all not awkward at all
helping deloney learn how to change the
diaper all those things right
and at the end of the day the picture's
different and so it's up to you to
adjust your picture because this is his
life
um and also you love him and you know
it's coming
he thinks he know his that he's just
gonna have a baby inserted into his
current life and you know when that baby
comes everything is different
everything is different and you know
that and it's hard to catch your breath
because you see what's coming he's about
to get hit in the mouth and you know it
and he's telling you Mom I'm cool I'm
I'm cool and you know you're not cool
so I'm just gonna hug you
and I'm gonna sit with you and when I'm
sad I'm gonna talk to my husband I'm
gonna talk to my counselor and talk to
my friends
and uh my son's not going to carry my
sadness that's not his job
he's gonna have enough trying to figure
out how to be a co-parent that's all
you're awesome Candace he's lucky to
have you lucky lucky to have you and all
the parents out there whose kids have
made decisions that you don't understand
they don't make sense that are dumb
they're idiotic that are lovely they're
just different than the way you did it
remember
their job is not to live your life their
job isn't to do everything the way you
wanted it done
their job is to just be your kid and
your job is to love them even if that
means hold them accountable having hard
conversations like get all that
but most of us need love
and connectivity
and then accountability not the other
way around we'll be right back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from our sponsor from betterhelp I've
been on the giving and receiving end of
therapy for years when I was spinning
out like a decade ago with wild anxiety
I had a moment that light bulb moment
that I knew I had to do something
different I knew I had to change
something probably a lot of some things
right but I found myself without the
tools for taking the next step
and when you're facing problems or
challenges in life it's way too easy to
get stuck in that anxious spiral of Doom
I've been there but when you learn how
to stop that cycle and start taking
ownership of your life that's when
you're free and that's what therapy can
help you do it gives you the tools you
need to do the problem solving in your
own life and that's why I love better
help better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist it's more
affordable than in-person therapy plus
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours if you're ready to get
the tools that you need to deal with the
curveballs life's thrown at you therapy
can help visit betterhelp.com deloni to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp.com deloney
all right we got unamas let's go to
Charles in Albany New York what's up
Charles
architecture podcast I'm going to talk
about Home Remodeling I'm I'm an expert
in Home Remodeling
um I'm actually an expert in starting no
I'm an expert in watching a bunch of
HGTV and getting a great idea and then
buying a bunch of junk and starting a
project and then never finishing it
that's one of my uh one of my gifts
awesome yeah so all right yeah out in
the world for you do what
can I put an idea out in the world for
you I would love that
I think you should do an entire episode
where everybody sings the whole time but
nobody ever refers to it and you can be
like can I be real with you real real
real with you yes please and genius
Chuck dude you've just yeah yes and yes
yes
I awesome I'm looking forward to seeing
it and no exit I would delete that
episode out of my own feet but it would
be worth doing this it'd be incredible
right after Hamilton part two comes out
we'll do it that'll be incredible we'll
have one oh that'd be so good actually
and if we could have one guy that just
like metal core sings it another guy
that raps it and that dude this is
Legend way to go man I'm gonna think
about this all day all right all right
so what's up
yeah so my question to you is how do I
stop comparing myself to my wife and I
can provide more context so you can just
riff off of that please provide more
context
does she have better hair than you is
she prettier than like what does she
have like why are you comparing her
what's the deal those things are true
but you know something that you
frequently talk about is how sort of a
lot of our happiness is based on the
picture we have of our life right in
most ways my life is actually much
better than I expected I have
interesting work that you know pays me
more than I I thought I'd ever make my
kids are awesomer than I thought you
know my wife as cool as I thought we'd
live in about you know so far so good
but I can't help but sort of look to my
right and see you know I'm middle
management a large company my wife is a
c-suite executive at a company you know
she helped take public last year you
know our kids are closer emotionally to
my wife and if I'm being honest with
myself she's just frankly smarter than I
am
and you know that's not because I'm
stupid it's because she's legitimately
brilliant right
um and you know you can sort of you read
about her in the newspaper or in you
know magazine you sort of come to the
same conclusion this person
brilliant so it's sort of like you know
being married to Athena I'm like well
you know I'm doing well for Immortal but
I'd like to be able to step on a cloud
and fly up to Mount Olympus too yeah and
it just you know it's a little hard to
to let go of that what is what is your
jealousy getting you
it gives you something what is it giving
you
and this isn't a trick question I'm
literally asking you it it solves a
problem for you in your life what is it
yeah I mean so
there is a bit more to the story
in the sense that I had
two pictures actually of my life that
were mutually incompatible
and I very explicitly
had to choose
One path to be with Leah
um and
maybe it's sort of
helps me
deal with sort of the loss of
the other
path that you know I enjoyed a lot were
you going to be an actor or something
like that in in art and you had to go
make a living
no
it was for National humanitarian worker
in Warzone yep and I I got to do that
but I sort of
really push the boundaries of safety to
the point where you know my wife was
saying look you know when I say tilt
death to us part I need that to be a
long time about a short time from now
so hold on hold on at that exact moment
at that moment
your wife presented you with a choice
and you chose her
right I do okay
any
any energy
spent going back and trying to re-edit
that decision
is a choice to be miserable in the
present
I had to do it too
I've done it several times
and I find myself when I'm tired when
I'm exhausted or when I'm feeling less
than I fall back into it
stop decisions I made 20 years ago
before I got married
my wife and I broke up what was going to
be the last time for about a year a long
time because I here was my rationale if
everything works out in my life the way
I want it to all my dreams come true and
all of your dreams come true we will end
up on opposite sides of the planet
and so why would we be together
knowing we're walking in and neither of
us are going to get what we think that
would fulfill us and what I found in
that journey is something I didn't know
existed
but that was my rationale and actually
logically that makes good logical sense
and it was the stupidest thing I've ever
the stupidest Choice I've ever made
but I tell you all that to tell you
you are really good linguistically
you can I bet people love being around
you at a party and you can be fun
and you can talk your way in and out of
things pretty well
yeah but
you underneath all of that are choosing
misery why what is it getting you
your kids aren't hanging out with your
wife because she's brilliant they're
hanging out with her more because she's
safer
you have a core of radioactivity about
you what is it and don't talk eloquent
just be direct what is it
only child don't care don't care you're
a grown man what what what is it getting
you
foreign
introverted despite being exuberant in
certain circumstances there you go
yeah
okay
so I I can't always handle like the
constantness of
just being a parent to three kids who I
I love like they're they're in
somebody's I love being a father more
than I thought but I like parenting
maybe less than I thought which here's
the deal brother here's the deal you
like the idea of liking things you don't
like them and you're not honest to
yourself about it
you like the idea of being a dad you
like the idea of being married to a
really brilliant powerful woman you like
the idea of working in a cool company
but you don't actually like the work
what do you actually like dude
I mean I think no no no what do you
actually like you're always saying maybe
and I think you know what do you
actually like
I love adventure and being in crazy
circumstances that I've never
experienced before yes and parenting is
so boring is
so boring
so boring and then you try to go on
adventure and one of your kids is like
I'm tired can I get a snack and you're
just like oh my God I get it yes
and so here's what's happening
you have a thing inside of you you love
Adventure
in a weird way you and I are very
similar I I don't have any interest in
going and being on the front lines in
third world countries and all that like
that's not my thing
but I did for about for multiple years
um
after my kids went to bed I went and ran
around with police officers in the
middle of crazy death scenes
because I needed that right yeah I went
and found it
but if you but right now you're doing it
at you're just not having this thing and
it is dragging everything else down
yeah see what I'm saying
yeah and I don't think your wife's
relate your relationship with your wife
is worth that I don't think your
relationship with your with your kids is
worth it I don't think in the reverse is
true
but you're on a fast track to resentment
brother and then right after resentment
is comes entitlement and then that's
when you start doing stupid things man
is that fair
yeah I mean I I hope I have the
self-awareness to be able to say my
emotional reaction is unfair
I mean my wife isn't putting any of
these expectations on me it's entirely
self-generated but you're trying to
solve all of this in your head and you
can't you have to act
foreign
yes no I my whole family tree we're all
in our heads for Generations mine too
you gotta act you have to do different
things and so when someone says Hey how
do I stop being jealous of my partner I
tell them go be more awesome
because the focus isn't on them the
focus is you are miserable as a middle
manager at a regular size corporation
surrounded by three kids in a big city
you see what I'm saying and when that
happens we make it everybody else it's
these stupid kids are just doing XYZ
it's my spouse is all brilliant I'm not
good enough that's not the issue that's
us trying to throw fishing lines of
blame out there and catch something that
will make us feel ah it's because of my
childhoods because I'm an only kid no I
don't care about any of that stuff it
probably matters down the way I just
don't care about it
right what I care about is you making a
couple of choices to be alive that don't
involve cheating on your wife and they
don't involve leaving your kids
yeah I mean occasionally I've I've found
opportunities that have a lot of
interesting international travel that do
make me feel alive but
it can create tension because I'm away a
lot and I don't actually want to be a
bad partner or parent and it kind of can
be an addiction absolutely it is what
are you running from
in some ways maybe the drudgery of life
like when you're
on the front lines it's very interesting
you don't have to do laundry and you
don't have to cook your own food
um I
I don't have a good answer
um how old are your kids
nine seven and four okay
let me let me
two things number one your kids are
watching their dad and they're learning
a picture of what Dad is supposed to be
and if Dad is kind of frumped out
and
let me put this away they will feel
whether you ever say it or not that
they're the reason you're not happy
because happiness is only on the front
lines of a thing
your wife will always feel that she
didn't fill in the blank
and they don't deserve that
definitely not what I would
your mission right now brother is to
come alive
and you're in a season
hang on and don't do something stupid
you're in a season man nine seven and
four
dude you've got three elementary school
kids
and one place you'll have a house or
apartment
we we have a house okay yeah yeah man
you're in a season so the question is
sitting down with your wife and saying
hey what do you need in this season
here's what I need I need some Adventure
I need to get my heart rate up that
might be in the bedroom that might be
I'm gonna join an MMA team I might be me
and I must have starting to ride along
with the police department that might
mean I'm gonna
get a weekend job clean and window I
don't know what gets your heart rate up
but let's say okay I can't go to
um the latest I can't go to Somalia I
can't go to wherever
where can I find purpose and Mission and
become alive in my current environment
in this season
yeah
see what I'm saying
it's like when I find myself in a hotel
room okay I don't have a huge gym what
can I do here right now that's going to
get my heart rate up it's going to keep
me healthy
it's not gonna be the greatest workout
ever I'm not gonna get shredded bro and
Crossfit none of that's gonna happen
but I'm going to be able to sleep
tonight I'm going to feel good and I'll
have moved my body and I'll keep moving
myself down the road towards becoming
the guy I want to be
yeah no that that all makes sense I mean
I I think I'm somebody who's naturally a
little bit
dissatisfied yes
um
why what are you dissatisfied from
in some way
some which state of the world the state
of myself I'm not quite as you know
awesome as I like to be hey okay so that
was Jolly Charles
you know kind of you know
I think you don't like you
I don't think you like the way you look
I don't think you don't like your job I
don't think you I think there's several
you just don't like you
why don't you like you
I think I could have done more with the
opportunities I've been given there you
go
foreign
so you feel like you're a failure and
you feel ashamed and you feel like man I
blew it
and now I'm stuck for the next 25 years
and then after that I'm like 58.
right
and then you fall into the boat that
most men fall into which is the one the
boat taking us on our lives of quiet
desperation this is just the way this is
going to be
and you'll either cheat on your wife and
everyone will be like what she was
brilliant beautiful what is he doing and
you will say because I finally felt
alive
or you will leave your kids and go to
some first world country or third world
country and to do a thing and you will
the whole time you're like I'm doing
good work my kids will
you're chasing something because you
can't look in the mirror and be happy
with who you see so what I would tell
you is maybe you did maybe you had some
cool opportunities and you blew it I
don't think so but maybe that's maybe
it's true
so here's the reality there's a period
at the end of that sentence
now what
because by continuing to focus on the
things you you've blown in the past you
screwed up in the past
you're screwing up your present
you're not living full see what I'm
saying
yeah that's that brick in the backpack I
talk about all the time
you wake up every morning with jolly
Charles and you open up your backpack
and you're like good morning and you
just start picking up the bricks and
putting them in there putting them in
there putting them in there I'm carrying
this around
and I guess so is are we meant to be
satisfied I mean in some ways
restlessness
has created
opportunity for me and I I make a lot of
strange choices but also that leads to
some really interesting outcomes
so I certainly understand
what you're saying
but also there's a part of me that if I
was too self-satisfied I'd be
dissatisfied with that
you've bought into an insane lie that
if you are at peace and you have joy in
your life that you can't be ambitious
that you can't go do good things
and that's Madness
in fact I would say the only way you can
do something good and healthy and well
sustainably over time is to find
equilibrium and then anchor off of there
and here's the here's the Charles curse
you're going to over analyze everything
yes and you're going to over analyze and
you're going to over analyze you're
going to over analyze and that's going
to keep you that's your buffer from ever
having to do anything
and so you're gonna have to choose when
those like Yeah but isn't nope stop I'm
not having that conversation I'm going
to exercise
okay yeah but nope I refuse to have that
con yes a Wandering spirit is good I
have one all over the place and I
desperately need people that keep me
Bound in
I love when I get nervous or I'd like I
go into my head I just sit there with my
data and I read and I need somebody to
say go to the gym
right right
you don't have man you don't have a a
you've bound yourself up into and tied
yourself to a mast of a ship heading in
just a circle in the bay
because it's just the way this is
I'm not meant to be at peace that's
stupid man yes you are I'm Not Meant To
Be You Are
and you can find adventure and you can
come alive in a million different ways
right where you're sitting
to feel like you have to have Adventure
overseas and to abandon your family and
to leave your wife
that's not about Adventure and that's
not about fulfillment that's about
running
[Music]
and
you're worth peace
stay on the line I'm going to send you
on your pass change your future I want
you to read it all the way through and I
want you to call me back
um
yours is kind of an extreme example
because your wife's super successful but
your situation is very very common and
I'm willing to walk alongside you if
you'll give me a call back in a couple
of months and let's continue to walk
down this road together and on the line
in general get you hooked up we'll be
right back
hey what's up now that my new book oh in
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right we are back hey um you always
hear me talking about our sponsor better
help right if you listen to this show
better help online therapy
you always you always get the
commercials about online therapy and
better help my relationship with them
here's a big deal to me whenever I was a
student affairs leader at a university
I'd always send out surveys I wanted the
students to have an opportunity to let
me know how I was doing how my team was
doing I'd send notes out to my staff I
wanted to know how am I doing how are we
doing so I reached out on social media
and asked you guys to send in some video
testimonies of
how is your better help online therapy
experience been I want to hear from you
I'm pushing this thing I've got a great
relationship with them the anecdotal
feedback I get is extraordinary right
it's so good
um so I asked for some video
testimonials some audio testimony like
let me know how this is going I want to
hear from you I want to see you how's
this actually going and it's important
to note um so I got I got submissions
from all over the country Jenna reached
out to him and they and distilled them
down got some good testimonials here
these are absolutely 100 not provided by
better help period I'm not paying these
people they're not paying me right these
are not any any sort of we're not trying
to play a gotcha
I wanted you folks to who are struggling
with I can't find a counselor in my area
I can't reach out to somebody on time
that I can't afford it
I want you to hear directly from people
who have called better help online
therapy and gotten gotten support and
the care they needed whether it was
long-term or just acute short-term care
I want you to hear directly from them in
a non-paid
non-pressured atmosphere Okay so
stay here check this out and um these
are three people who have experienced
better help personally here's what they
have to say
the past two years has been a lot for
everyone across the globe and it's been
a lot for me personally so I decided to
use better help or therapy because I was
entering a new season of my life I have
been on better health for about two
weeks now I've experienced job loss
moving across the country when I was
nine months pregnant becoming a
first-time parent to my beautiful
daughter learning how to make new
friends in the midst of the isolation of
the pandemic and losing my cousin due to
mental illness new relationship we're
talking about our future together new
promotion at work a bunch of new stress
in my life both good and bad that I was
working through and trying to make sure
that I'm using every tool in the toolbox
that I possibly could it was a lot and
so I decided to take up Dr John aloni's
recommendation to use better help using
his promo code and I was matched with
counselors who are able to talk me
through my feelings and what had
recently happened my therapist and I we
communicate in many different ways we
have a chat session that we can go back
and forth if I have a story that is
going to be a little too long for
texting I can record myself and send it
to her as an audio file and we also have
live sessions it was a great experience
my therapist that I was matched with she
helped me identify how different traumas
and experiences in my life were
affecting the way I react to things now
she helped me with strategies on how to
approach situations that work better how
not to take work home with me how to
approach conversations with my partner
better I've had a really great
experience with her we have communicated
on all these different topics such as
Parenthood marriage even just some
conversations regarding boundaries with
my with my family that I grew up with we
talked about my marriage my mental
health setting healthier boundaries how
I can make new friends what I should say
yes and no to it was a great experience
it was somebody who's dealt with anxiety
his entire life it was by far the best
counseling experience I've ever had
can't recommend it enough and especially
as you enter different seasons of your
life I think it's a great opportunity to
make sure you're using all the tools you
possibly can I highly encourage everyone
to check it out I think it's been very
enriching for myself and I think it
could be for you all too I would
recommend it to all of my family and
friends to give it a try and I'd highly
recommend it to you
all right as we wrap up today's show
we've done this song before but this was
James favorite song and since today is
James official last day as a part of the
Dr John deloney team
Kelly
[Music]
let's do this thing song is ever long by
the great Foo Fighters and it goes like
this hello I've waited here for you ever
long and tonight I throw myself into
and out of the red out of her head she's
saying come down and waste away with me
down with me slow how you want it to be
I'm over my head out of her head she's
saying and I wonder when I sing along
with you if everything could ever feel
just real forever if anything could ever
be this good again the only thing I'll
ever ask of you you gotta promise not to
stop when I say when we'll see you soon